when Mark hayatun was 69 he was
diagnosed with squamous cell thymic
carcinoma a deadly cancer that affects
the lymphatic and endocrine systems his
doctor told him he likely had months to
live one of the most frightening things
I've ever seen was sort of by accident
when I saw medical consultants laptop
the scan metastases to lungs liver
thoracic cavity my right humerus my left
scapula that was six years ago he
survived thanks to an experimental drug
that rapidly shrank his tumors and eased
his pain what's particularly noteworthy
about Mark hatin surprising recovery was
that the drug that saved his life hadn't
been approved by the FDA that would come
six years later at which point Hayden
probably would have been long dead he
was able to take it anyway thanks to
write to try a legal movement that led
to the passage of laws in 41 states
allowing doctors to prescribe terminal
patients with experimental drugs that
haven't passed muster with regulators
some bills they don't have a good name
okay hey really but this is such a great
name for the first day I heard it it's
so perfect right to try in May of 2019
President Trump
signed right to try into federal law it
was championed by Vice President Mike
Pence who had signed a version of the
legislation himself in 2015 whatever
happens next I've had a great quality of
life we've continued to travel we've
been able to take our grandchildren on
trips mark Hayden's story underscores
the deadly consequences of FDA overreach
the right to try laws which were
engineered by a small free-market
think-tank in Arizona called the
Goldwater Institute are a shot across
the bow at the FDA's core mission it's a
real culture change in Washington DC
it's one of the first times in recent
history where Congress has told the FDA
you're overstepping your boundaries and
I think that that's not the end of the
story this is just the beginning
concern over the tragic effects of the
new sedative felid amide prompts
President Kennedy at his press
conference to call for stronger better
administered drug laws founded in 1906
the Food and Drug Administration didn't
become a powerful force in American
health care until the 1960s when the
sedative called thalidomide was marketed
to pregnant women in Europe it turned
out that when their mothers took
thalidomide about 40% of babies died in
utero or shortly after birth those that
survived often had severe birth defects
like shorten limbs and deformed organs
Americans mostly dodged the thalidomide
tragedy thanks to FDA physician Francis
Oldham Kelsey who was concerned about
its safety and kept it off the US market
her decision saved thousands of lives
and earned her the Presidential Medal of
Freedom at the time the FDA's mandate
was to determine if a drug had dangerous
side effects before approving it for use
after the thalidomide scandal a new law
gave the agency broad authority to
determine if new drugs also did what
they claimed and to prevent Americans
from trying them until its investigation
was complete it turned out there was an
enormous cost to caution solid amides
hidden victims were those denied access
to life-saving medicines because of
regulatory overreach in the decade after
the FDA expanded its scope new drug
approvals fell by about two-thirds today
the average cost to get a drug passed
the FDA to market has risen to 2.7
billion dollars and the number of new
drugs approved per billion dollars spent
has halved every nine years since 1960
and yet there was little public outrage
over the impact on medical innovation
images of children deformed in utero by
an untested drug spur public action but
the victims of a regulatory environment
that limits access and curbs innovation
go unnoticed but libertarian reformers
at the Goldwater Institute discovered
one scenario that the public could rally
around cases in which terminally ill
patients are denied the right to try
experimental drugs
David Huntley
who suffered from ALS a
neurodegenerative disease that destroys
all motor function fought for access to
a drug in clinical trials that could
slow the progression of his disease FDA
impeded his access to GM 604 a
potentially life-altering treatment
without any treatment I will pass in
three to nine months how is keeping a
potentially life-saving drug from me
saving my life a decision to use an
investigational drug to fight a fatal
disease should be between a patient and
his or her doctor Huntley died in July
2015 and never got access to GM 604
which is in limbo after completing phase
two clinical trials in September 2016
ALS sufferers testified before Congress
right now we have no so is either you
know hope or no this bill it doesn't do
everything but it moves us in the
direction of having a little bit of Hope
when chemotherapy failed to shrink mark
Hansen's tumors there were no FDA
approved treatment options left but he
was accepted into a clinical trial run
by dr. Ibrahim tapas and a nuclear
oncologist testing an experimental drug
called lutetium one-77 Doda Tate it
turned out to have very few side effects
many of our patients if you look at them
you can't even tell that they are
undergoing cancer therapy so typically
they don't lose their hair they don't
get sick my cough disappeared the tumor
started to shrink and people literally
thought I was cured nobody knew why it
was working but it was working at the
end of the final phase three clinical
trials the drug had eliminated tumors
and a majority of patients after the
trial concluded two and a half years
went by before the FDA would approve the
drug in the meantime dr. Dell pass and
requested permission from the agency to
continue administering it to
participants like hayatun who were being
kept alive by the treatment and two new
patients with endocrine cancer many
cancer patients they can't wait their
disease in a advanced phase and if we
lose that momentum if we do not give
them the treatment on time
essentially we lose that opportunity to
control the disease his request was
denied it was a very difficult time for
me at that point because what can I tell
these patients and their family members
hareton asked the FDA to reconsider the
FDA's wrote a nice letter to me saying
well thanks very much but we can see you
didn't have fact have a complete
response and I said well maybe not but I
would have been dead before I was
writing this letter and without the
response I did have and only a few
cancers have the possibility so far of
complete responses the odds are already
so stacked against the patient it
doesn't help to have the FDA taking
positions like this the FDA should never
be the decision-maker the FDA can
require testing the FDA can make sure
that people have enough information so
that they can make good decisions but at
the end of the day it should be the
patient and the doctor who are the ones
that are making the decision the
Goldwater Institute presented the
problems that dr. Dell Passons patients
were having to the Texas Legislature
which quickly passed a right to try a
law
Hansen got continued access to the
treatment as did 77 of Dell Passons
other patients in the roughly two years
between when the FDA told him to stop
giving these treatments to patients to
when the treatment was finally approved
for market he treated about 200 patients
and many of them were told they only had
months to live and many of them are
still alive today though the FDA
declined our interview requests the
agency has emphasized its own expanded
access program called compassionate use
which allows some terminal patients to
try experimental drugs according to a
2017 Government Accountability Office
report the FDA approved five thousand
six hundred ninety seven of 5753
requests that came through the
compassionate use program between 2012
and 2015
critics argue that because of this
program right to try laws are
superfluous but before right to try
getting approval through compassionate
use involved significant bureaucratic
hurdles according to the nonprofit
regulatory affairs right to try a state
laws pressured the FDA to streamline the
application process Dell Pass and used
the FDA's expanded
access program to provide some of his
patients with the drug but once the drug
was on track for commercial approval the
FDA wouldn't let him enroll any new
patients it was only through Texas's
right to try law that the rest of Delp a
sentence patients including hayatun were
able to continue to get their treatment
I wouldn't be sitting here talking to
you now if compassionate use was all I
had had right to try allows
pharmaceutical companies to sell
experimental drugs at costs and unlike
compassionate use protects them from
liability and reporting requirements if
a patient dies or suffers on account of
a bad reaction no pharmaceutical in
their right mind would give me a drug
compassionately because if I have an
adverse event which you know I'm an als
patient let's face it I probably will
they have to report that to the FDA and
it's going to jeopardize and they're
trying drug approvals have been derailed
in the past by adverse effects occurring
under compassionate use a patient should
be able to weigh the potential that the
drug might not work or the drug might
have very serious side effects against
the potential that the drug could
actually save their lives nobody can
make that decision for a patient that is
up to the individual themselves not a
drug company and had a doctor and
certainly not the FDA critics also say
right to try has only helped a small
number of patients so far although there
are no official numbers to date Sandefur
says she expects that to change as drug
manufacturers and doctors become more
familiar with the law right to try is a
very small but a very important first
step in the right direction ultimately I
would love to see a system that is more
patient centric I would love to see a
system that gives patients more options
so they don't have to be beholden to the
FDA and this is specially true of
terminally ill patients because when
people are fighting for their lives they
shouldn't have to fight the government
as well Sandefur says that right to try
is just the beginning of the push for
greater pharmaceutical freedom policy
researcher Bartley Madden for example
has floated a proposal already being
implemented in Japan under which any
patient could access experimental drugs
that
pass initial safety screenings without
any FDA involvement at all
their outcomes would be logged in
publicly accessible databases enabling a
freer flow of information and possibly
faster breakthroughs thanks to write to
try mark hayatun has lived for six years
beyond his doctor's initial expectations
time that he spent with his wife of 54
years vacationing with his grandchildren
and caring for his elderly mother but
recently his cancer returned and he's
now searching for another miracle I
don't know how soon this journey will
end but I am really grateful for right
to try
[Music]